all right we've been waiting for this we
now have three new polls after last
week's Democratic primary debates and it
turns out that my analysis of who did
well has translated directly into
polling changes and I want to go over
those with you today the the big picture
is Joe Biden is down Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren are basically even worn
up slightly Kamala Harris got the
biggest boost while basically all of the
zeros and ones the people polling 0 & 1
or even up to 2 percent are basically
unchanged and some of them probably
should start getting out of the race
soon and we'll talk about that in a
little bit so to remind you my analysis
was that on the first night Elizabeth
Warren won she was the strongest on
policy she didn't win in dramatic
fashion she didn't have any of those big
gotcha type moments that unfortunately
in the modern political environment are
considered signs of strength as a
politician I also thought that from
night one who Leon Castro and Bill
DeBlasio did well but they didn't have a
chance and they continued not to have a
chance on night 2 Kamala Harris was
clearly the winner in the way that a
mildly involved Democratic voter would
see it very strong and commanding Budaj
edge sort of in a quiet
second place Bernie Sanders may be right
there with him maybe in third place
Bernie likely not doing damage but not
really making any big gains was my
impression and the poll results
basically have confirmed that that's the
way that on average Democratic voters
understood the debates so looking at the
averages of the three recent polls
rather than at any one poll Joe Biden's
polling continues to trickle down that's
the Green Line at the top for people who
are watching
Bernie's polling is basically even the
slightest uptick about half of one point
Elizabeth Warren continuing this slow
and steady climb that goes all the way
back to early April and then the biggest
jump very clearly is that orange line on
the chart Kamala Harris Harris gained
more than three full points she's now
within striking distance of Elizabeth
Warren for third place who herself is
now within striking distance of Bernie
Sanders for second place and if Joe
Biden doesn't turn this trend around Joe
Biden actually
falling out of first place before he
knows it you will also notice that the
zeros and ones as I call them the people
basically polling nothing have not
really moved
none of those lower down in the polling
have moved the needle a Marianne
Williamson was polling almost has been
polling almost literally zero she's now
at 0.2 percent that may even be a drop
from before the debate I don't remember
jay Inslee is at 0.3 percent
bill de blasio is up to 0.7 percent from
I think like 0.5 I mean this is
basically all 0 so in total Williamson
Inslee de Blasio Delaney Bennett Castro
Ryan Bullock Klobuchar Seth Moulton who
wasn't even in the debates and Kirsten
Gillibrand all under 1% and then you
have Tulsi Gabbard and Andrew yang
between one and two percent now those
two are interesting names yang
supporters were saying hoping that
Andrew yang would explode after his
participation in the first debate hasn't
happened admittedly he didn't get much
of a chance to talk Tulsi Gabbard
supporters loudly saying before the
debate that she was going to explode as
soon as the country became more aware of
her her polling hasn't moved at all
either and it's interesting to note that
there was a lot of bragging after the
debates from supporters of some of these
lower polling candidates saying X was
the most searched-for candidate on
Google right after the debate they're
going to explode in the polls and what I
was saying at the time and and clearly
is is true is that just because a lot of
people are googling someone's name
doesn't mean they're impressed with them
or plan to vote for them for example
marianne williamson was saying wacky
things and no one knew who she was so it
makes sense that a lot of people would
start searching her name on google to
figure out who she is not necessarily to
vote for her and the polling seems to
bear that out
Tulsi Gabbard I hate to break it to
people but she a lot of the the searches
for Tulsi Gabbard were because she did
make Tim Ryan look really stupid on that
issue of the Taliban also if you looked
at a lot of the comments online it
clearly appears that there are lots of
men who are quite taken and
women potentially quite taken with an
attractive 30-something year old
candidate and they didn't know who she
was so they were googling her name it is
not translating into polling growth at
least not in the three post-debate polls
so far andrew yang again lots of
searches for andrew yang picked up a lot
of twitter followers doesn't mean that
this is someone who's google searches
are necessarily going to translate into
polling support so the question now
starts to become how long are some of
these zeros and ones going to stay in
for those who were in the debate they
don't seem to have gained polling
support and that's something they're
going to have to think about the the
zeros and ones who didn't even make the
debates which are Seth Moulton and there
might be one or two others it's just
time for them to go I mean they never
had a chance to begin with and they
should go on the show tomorrow I'm going
to address a question that our audience
is very divided about the question is
when does this polling matter in the
sense of historically when do polling
numbers start to reflect who is likely
to actually secure nominations the
answer is it's right around now but I'm
gonna go into detail about that on
tomorrow's program lastly there are
people who are emailing me saying David
you should not be looking at national
polls you should be looking at the Iowa
caucus polls because that's the first
caucus I believe it's in January
February and that's going to set the
tone for how the entire primary goes
yeah I mean it's fine to do that it's
not actually that interesting yet
because right now there's this 15%
cutoff in the Iowa caucuses if you don't
get 15% support you don't get any
delegates from the Iowa caucus right now
it would just be Biden and Sanders who
get any delegates from Iowa and that's
the way it's been for a while so in fact
that hasn't really changed no one else
is polling at 15% in Iowa although I
believe Pete Budaj
is close maybe at 12% just shy of the
15% requirement so yeah you will start
looking at Iowa when it's actually
closer right now the national polls
actually do tell us quite a bit if you
disagree with me let me know I've been
open to having my mind changed about
this for months but so far it's been
more or less as our analysis has
predicted one of today's sponsors is
impeach the card slap game you can't
slap Donald Trump in real life but you
can slap him in this really funny and
intelligent two-player card game and you
can get it for ten percent off when you
go to david pakman.com slash impeach and
use the coupon code pakman show at
checkout all one word impeach the card
slap game is perfect for having friends
over or hanging out with family members
who have a sense of humor about trump
we've been playing it at my place it
currently has a five out of five star
rating on amazon I really don't think
you'll be able to find a game that does
a better job of satirizing today's
political climate in such an intelligent
way I've had a ton of fun with it and I
think you will too
you can tell a ton of time and careful
thought went into the game design and
the cartoon artwork and the humor it
never gets old because you're always
discovering new jokes and political
commentary within the game we were
talking to the creators of the game and
they said one of their goals was that
players might even learn something new
as they play I think it would make a
perfect gift for anyone really of any
political orientation just because of
how clever it is or you can get it for
yourself and have a really fun and witty
game to play when people come over get
impeach the cards slap game by going to
david pakman.com slash impeach and get
10% off when you use the coupon code
pakman show at checkout that's all one
word Pakman show